no matter where you go of what they may
call you you always be nice Lupita
Nyong'o lends her vocal talents to
Disney's Magical reincarnation of The
Jungle Book
as mother wolf Raksha a role as I
learned she was born to play not being a
mother yourself how did you connect to
her well I've always loved children and
I've been fantasizing about motherhood
since I was like three really so for me
this was some this was an opportunity
for me to tap into that natural instinct
that I think we all have within us to
bring forth life and to protect it and
now our returning to where he belongs
I won't let you he's my cup I have a
mother who is fierce yes and she she is
known to say things like if you die I'll
kill you and so I really do try her yes
I definitely channeled my mother do you
think you'll be that fierce when you
finally become a mother one day I mean
I'm the kind of person if I'm walking
with a parent and their child I'm the
one who's worried right about the child
getting on so I'm I think I'm gonna be
one of those very scary mothers who
doesn't let anyone hear I hear a baby
cry no it won't be because it'll be
right here